avec toutes qu'est ce qui s'passe pizzo
des problèmes de main d'oeuvre qu'on a
quand même pas toutes nos travailleurs
d'arriver plus température comme sur fo
qui plaide ici je te dirais les
prochaines deux à trois semaines
parce que les réserves d'eau sont base
marcel groleau et le président général
de l'union des producteurs agricoles
marcel groleau bonsoir oui bonsoir
gerald d'abord je vous parlais de
lakovic 19 ces décès de travailleurs
étrangers temporaires ça s'est passé en
ontario nous dit on se le dit à des
centaines de cas apparemment est ce que
vous avez pu avoir conscience que des
agriculteurs qui ne respectent pas
présentement les règles de santé
publique
le concepteur non présentement au québec
moi j'ai pas eu d'informations comme
quoi des producteurs ne respectaient pas
les consignes l'isolément qui a été
obligé la protection des travailleurs
je vous dirais que le log risques pour
les travailleurs étrangers actuellement
c'est la circulation sur les fermes des
travailleurs locaux qui sortent et entre
à chaque jour parce que les travailleurs
étrangers sont relativement bien
protégés
plusieurs entreprises des ans isolé des
travailleurs locaux pour justement
s'assurer qu'ils aient pas de
contamination mais mais mais j'allais y
sont exposés comme le premier ministre
hugo a dit ce matin que les règles n'ont
pas été respectées par tous et qu'il y
aurait des conséquences pour des
entreprises agricoles dont il parlait
pour l'ensemble du canada le jossec en
ontario il ya eu plus de contamination
de travers à l'étranger que au québec
alors je vous pose la question moi c'est
ça moi ce que je j'ai comme information
il ya eu une contamination chez la ferme
matches pros et monsieur van welden a
pris des mesures très très strict le
pour isoler ces travailleurs ceux qui
étaient contaminés ce qui ne l'était pas
alors il ya même demandé l'aide de la
santé publique alors loin de se cacher
ils demandent aux autorités de l'aider
mais dans ce cas là il
demain la contamination ou venez pas de
travailleurs qui sont arrivés ici
infectés mais était en les travailleurs
ont été infectées par les travailleurs
québécois qui allait sur latvala
c'est une situation ces travailleurs de
sont à risque comme les citoyens
québécois d'être contaminé par quelqu'un
qui est asymptomatique
alors c'est des situations qui doivent
être gérées au cas le corps par des
entreprises agricoles lorsque ça arrive
mais c'est juste dans le traitement des
personnes il faut juste que ce soit
c'est là l'enjeu c'est est ce que ces
gens là sont bien reçus bien traité
exactement comme c'est prévu ou est ce
qu'il ya des cas où c'est pas bien
appliquées
c'est ça la question c'est ça nous on
était très clair avec les producteurs
ceux qui ne respecteront pas les règles
prévues au protocole qui ont été
convenues par la csst et la santé
publique
également par le gouvernement fédéral
s'expose à de fortes pénalités
oui et nous on les protège la peau et on
les descendre pour les producteurs le
savent très bien
ils doivent prendre soin de leurs
travailleurs il manque beaucoup sur
ledit de travailleurs étrangers n'est ce
pas en ce moment et en manque encore
parce qu'il ya 3000 travailleurs du
mexique qui sont toujours attendus
est-ce qu'ils vont arriver bon show
courant de l'entente qui était convenu
le pour qu'ils puissent mais vous avez
un mexicain puce continuer de venir
mais la saison avance 6 arrivions 14
jours d'isolement à faire avant de
pouvoir travailler alors c'est ce que
pour les frais il on est en pleine
saison des fraises actuellement pour ces
producteurs l'oeil est pratiquement trop
tard la saison de récolte dans les
légumes vont commencer aussi salades et
autres
alors oui on espère qu'ils vont arriver
mais plus le temps passe plus ce fait
ans et il n'y a pas un grand nombre de
québécois finalement qui ont été
assignés à des installations agricoles
n'est ce pas il y en a on avait 1600
travailleurs
donc on avait mêlée tous les to en fait
je devrais vous expliquer que tous les
travailleurs québécois sur les fermes
n'ont pas nécessairement été référées
via le programme qui a été mis en place
sont tous admissibles
place au programme là mais certains se
sont rendus directement sur les
entreprises ou les entreprises avait des
contacts et ont engagé nos gens qui le
connaissaient mais il ya plus de
travailleurs québécois sur les femmes
cette année qu'habituellement il ya eu
un reportage dans la presse plus
d'ailleurs dans cette semaine daphné
cameron une de ses collègues sur des
expériences qu'ont vécu les étudiants
donc oui les arrières les entreprises
sont de plus en plus appel à des
travailleurs québécois pour combler
l'absence de neuf étrangers
et puis les précipitations qui sont
quand même très très faible puis on voit
les feux de forêt incroyable aussi avec
mary sécheresse et tout le monde pense
elle est à même de constater la
sécheresse le temps très sec et quand on
regarde quelques exemples on voit que
les précipitations en 2020 par rapport à
ce qu'on a connu dans le passé des
régions comme hemmingford
saint-louis-de-blandford
brownsburg-chatham on est entre 41 42 %
des précipitations à bissau devant
l'assomption se fait montréal
frelighsburg saguenay entre 50 et 60
pour ça c'est très faible est ce que ça
va causer des dommages importants
assurément assurément d'autant plus
qu'il fait très chaud parce qu'il faut
combiner les effets aussi et des faibles
précipitations et de l'échelle des
chaleurs extrêmes que nous avons qui
favorise aussi l'évaporation de l'eau
sur les sols et dans les plans alors
c'est une saison chez nous sur la ferme
ici la première coupe est pratiquement
terminé et on a 50 % des rendements
habituels c5 vraiment très très sec
je parle à d'autres producteurs
aujourd'hui dans la région de l'estrie
savary de d'un secteur à l'eau c'est
peut-être là où c'est actuellement le
moins problématique dans le bas saint
laurent c'est très très sec également
ils ont eu très peu de précipitations
alors s'il ya pas de plus rapidement le
j'entends d'un de vos intervenants tous
qui peut-être qui va parler après moi
mais qui dit que ça prend de la pluie
d'ici deux à trois semaines moi je dis
ça prend de la pluie dans les prochains
jours dans deux à trois semaines pour
plusieurs producteurs un fou au niveau
de la production fourragère
il sera trop tard au niveau des
producteurs maraîchers plusieurs voix
leurs réserves d'eau diminué de façon
importante et très rapide
alors ces critiques on est à un moment
critique il faut vraiment avoir des
précipitations est ce que c'est ce qu'on
est capable de rattraper les retards qui
sont enregistrés présentement en raison
des sécheresses
je dirais que c'est probablement pas
entièrement la première coupe de foin
pour caen pour 40% de la production
annuelle habituellement alors quand la
moitié de cette première coupe là
seulement en termes de rendement c'est
difficile à rattraper avec les codes
suivants
je dirais que les pâturages ou si on en
parle peu mais les éleveurs de veaux
d'embouché envoient leurs vaches au
pâturage avec leur vaut ces pâturages là
sur un nouvel pas suffisamment ils vont
marquer de points rapidement
ça aussi ce sera dur pour eux ce sera
des pertes importantes puis ce qui est
important ou ce qui est différent cette
année que ça touche l'ensemble du québec
alors il y aura pas de point à vendre
dans les autres régions pour les régions
qui sont frappés par la sécheresse
donc ça risque de coûter très cher pour
soit acheter des points de l'extérieur
du québec voire même des états unis pour
combler nos besoins
alors moi je suis très inquiet de la
situation actuellement c'est pas simple
d'être agriculteur en ce moment avec
tout ce que vous vivez depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant c'est vraiment là non
vraiment cette année c'est compliqué
c'est vraiment compliqué absolument
merci beaucoup
ça me plaisait au revoir